hello everyone and welcome to another
most anticipated game uh from round 12
of the golden money asian rapid
um uh tournament it's bhaskaran adiban
versus anishigiri and
everyone is always excited when ariband
plays with the white pieces as everyone
is asking the same question will he open
with one to be
three or will it be uh something else
and here
uh he stays true to his uh to his
chestable course and he does it again he
opens with one to b3 and against none
other than um
well probably one of the maybe not one
of the probably the most
knowledgeable uh player there is today
anishigiri
it's uh incredibly difficult to surprise
him and do no more theory than him
uh but in this particular opening i
guess it could be possible so uh let's
see what happens here so b3 by adiman
uh also known as the names of which
larson attack but uh slowly becoming
known as the nimsovich larsen adiban
attack
uh we have d5 by giri uh this is the
classical reply to the
to this move and knight to f3 we have
bishop to f5 with the early development
of the light square bishop
uh bishop to b to end now e6 so now
uh the bishop has been developed and the
pawns have been put on light square so
you don't have to worry about the bishop
being stuck on c8
for a very long time we have d3 and now
h6 making sure
that if this bishop is attacked with
maybe knight to h4 or something not
right away but later on
you can always tuck it away safely to h7
we have knight beat to d2
and not knight to f6 with g3 preparing
to fiance to the light square bishop as
well
and bishop to h7 now we have bishop to
g2 and the bishop to e7
and now there is one game in the
database where castles was played but
here we have e4 by adiban and it is now
uh already as of move eight that we have
a completely new game
so on each castles uh we have queen to
e2 continuing development now
uh considering both kingside and
queenside castles all depending on what
anish plays and here
anish starts with a5 he wants to expand
uh as much as possible on the queen side
so if he castles queen side then he
already has a4 he wants to open up the
position and he will have
a nice open uh file for his rook
so here a3 expecting a4 and preparing to
counter this will be for we have a for
bionic
and b for now but now c5 challenging
this uh
b4 pawn and if you don't react to this
then just captures captures and black
already has a past a pawn
uh so here adiban advances the pawn to
b5
and now comes uh even c4 uh so if adiban
didn't advance this and
if he traded for example on c5 then
anish would just activate this dark
square bishop and it would be an
incredibly strong piece
so here uh he plays c4 he wants to
attack the d3 pawn and weaken the e4
pawn
so adiban accepts this we have d
captures and c4
knight captures on e4 and now aliban
castles the safety
uh we have knight to d7 and each
continues developing pieces now the uh
this knight can come to f6 also you can
play bishop to f6 the counterweight's
dark square bishop here on b2
we have rook 8 to d1 and now bishop to
f6 but now
uh now only now we have knight captures
on e4
and anish doesn't capture here on e4 he
instead picks up the dark square bishop
as this is an incredibly powerful piece
so bishop captures on b2 we have c
captures on d5e captures and
rook capture so for the moment adiban is
up upon uh but not for long as i need
you can grab this a3 pawn whenever he
wishes so and then he will have created
a past a pawn
so queen to e7 getting the queen out of
this uh nasty
uh nasty square we have knight after d2
now there's a double attack on the
knight so you have to defend it and you
can't really move this knight because
well the the queen would hang here uh
even if you play something like knight
to c3 to
try and defend the knight yes you can
play this but then captures captures
knight f6 black has a very very
comfortable game
uh so instead after queen to a7 we have
knight f2d2 just defending the knight
uh and now just bishop captures an a3
here anish could uh
try to increase the pressure a little
bit before just grabbing the pawn
uh but he decides to claim it and now he
has a past a pawn and he wants to push
it to the victory
so knight to c4 now attacking the bishop
and here what do you play
well uh you could always capture the
knight here on e4 but you can always do
that so we're not gonna
mention it right away here on each plate
bishop to b4
but now c3 further harassing the bishop
we have bishop to a5
and now even b6 this opens up a double
attack on the bishop here
and there is no good move for this
bishop uh
so you have to find something else uh
there is of course
uh just bishop captures on e4 that's
always in the position just captures
captures for example and then you play
some like rook after e8 you pile up on
this bishop
and you completely ignore that this
bishop is attacked twice so this is one
way to play it
but anish decides to go with f5
now like we said this knight can't
really move because well you will lose
the queen
uh but there is a very interesting move
that
wins the game for adiban so feel free to
pause the video
and try to find this idea while i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on
finding uh such an incredible sequence
of moves and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show
uh it's knight capture sunday seven this
is not what was played in the game but
knight captures on d7 is just deadly
because after queen captures you have
this knight to c5 now
with an attack on the queen and with a
double attack on the b7 pawn so here you
will create a very strong past
b6 pawn so after the queen moves attacks
the white queen we can trade here let's
say captures captures and then we pick
up this pawn
and now this pawn is a monster but uh
you can't really move the the rook
because if the rook moves then
you're going to lose the bishop here so
best you have is just to give up the
bishop for this
past pawn and after knight captures we
can attack the bishop let's say bishop
d5 check
and we end the variation with white
having two knights
for a rook which is of course much
better and the white would have uh
would have a winning winning advantage
here
uh but instead after f5 adiban played
knights the
f6 with check seems like a weird thing
to do because there's nothing on f6
but and now you have to capture with the
queen if you don't you're going to lose
the queen here
so here queen captures on f6 was played
and now he captures on d7 and now he's
still attacking the b7 pawn twice so
it's kind of the a similar idea but not
quite the same now anish grabs the c3
pawn
and here comes bishop captures on b7 you
could also capture with the rook
it's uh basically a matter of preference
we have rook 8 to b8 now
and here comes knight captures on a5 and
this is just incredibly strong because
now queen captures an a5
and bishop to d5 with check with king to
h8 and now queen to e5 threatening
checkmate
and you don't really have a good way of
defending this because you can block
with rook to g8
but the g8 square is covered by our good
friend the bishop
so here rook the g8 is played but he
doesn't
just pick it up uh you you could do this
but
there's no reason to do it right away
here adiban just plays
rook to c1 and now he will make a second
rook lift here and that's going to be
unstoppable
we have queen capture some b6 by anish
but now bishop captures on g8 we have
rook capture so you still have to defend
against checkmate
and now rook c to c7 again going after
this g7 pawn
and there's nothing anish can do here he
tried f4 it's a very nice trick if it
works
but rook captures on g7 uh we have queen
to b1
with check now king g2 and now even f3
hoping to get some uh maybe maybe king
captures an f3 then queen to h1 check
maybe you can still pull something off
but ottoman just ignores him he plays
king to h3
now comes queen to f5 with check and now
uh well what do you do here there are
many ways to end this game but the
cleanest one than the one other one
chooses is just
g4 he sacrifices the queen and it was in
this position
uh on move uh uh 35 that anish geary
resigned the game
because there is nothing more to be done
here if you don't take the queen then
wherever the rook moves it's just uh you
know brutal just rook captures here
would be
a checkmate because it would be check
from the queen and from the rook
and of course if the queen is accepted
then rook captures an h7 is checkmate
and
that's that's all there is uh so yeah uh
adiman finishes the game with the g4
and an incredible victory for him in
round 12 with none other than
one b3 so the nimzo larsen adivan
opening
attack strikes again uh so there you
have it i'm very interested if any of
you guys are using this or uh
you know is is i know it's gaining a lot
on popularity but
is it gaining uh by you playing it or
just by people knowing about it so
that's what i what i would be very
interested i
i i did some uh work on it maybe some
four years ago and i did enjoy playing
it and i actually
uh managed to to beat some uh strong
players even in classical chess
uh so it's a very in it's a very
interesting opening and as you can see
you can even use it to take down a
monster like like anish
on his birthday so that's that's pretty
ruthless of ariban but
what are you going to do so yeah once
again i hope you guys enjoyed it
i would like to thank andre sandu david
kimura nigel holloway happy birthday
gavin and
leander mother mother stone for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this very
nice tournament
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day